the Tower of Babel the story of how one
original language shattered into many
was one of humanity's early attempts to
explain languages thousands of years
later linguists investigated exactly how
languages evolved when they put the
pieces together though did it look
anything like the Babel story or was
this just a tall tale so the story goes
the whole earth once spoke the same
language ye hold awed itself i hath one
day they traveled to the land of Shinar
where they worked together to build a
city with a mcdowell a tower to reach to
the skies their supreme deity wasn't
having it though and scrambled their
language so they could no longer
understand each other this stories stuck
jewish writers speculated what the
original Adamic language was and how
many tongues it split in two was it 70
or 72 a Persian contended Adamic might
be Syriac while this Syrian went with
Hebrew Europeans claimed everything from
Swedish to Irish which apparently just
picked out the best bits of those 72
original flavors still Hebrew remained
the prime candidate after all it's the
language of this story right details
changed but the interpretation held one
original tongue at a single place in
time broke into a bunch of distinct
languages in order to keep people from
coordinating and understanding each
other then came the 17 and 1800's
explorers and trade routes shrank the
world distant people discovered each
other's languages for the first time
intrigued scholars found common patterns
that shifted our view of the world's
languages some languages consistently
looked at week away from each other
take Arabic and Hebrew vibe and Civ Vaca
and Zaha behind these words there's a
regular sound correspondence where
Arabic has vowel Hebrew has Zion
these were cognates the same word
evolving differently in different
languages comparing cognates a picture
emerged of a family tree walking back up
the branches of the tree you could
reconstruct the common ancestor but
testing this method in the wild world
the trails of cognates didn't lead back
to a single proto-language know there
were clusters of closely and distantly
related languages belonging to separate
families English Irish
Greek and even Sanskrit were clearly
part of an indo-european language family
from the South China Sea to the eastern
Pacific the languages of Austronesian
aired their own common ancestor and
Hebrew once dubbed the original language
fits snugly among its kin one twig of an
afro-asiatic family it wasn't even the
purest or best preserved twig for
example it were away consonant
distinctions that its relatives Aramaic
and Arabic kept also change turned out
to be something languages were doing
naturally all of the time Babel still
held one intriguing idea over us though
that original language see
reconstructions dead ended several
thousand years back beyond that
historical linguists started to feel
like they simply had nothing to say
nothing to say I will tie your own hands
but you can't hold back a maverick
so you established families and
reconstructed parent languages well why
not do the same thing again compare
proto languages for cognates and build
families on top of families families are
coming together it's a super family
enter the late Josef Greenberg classify
languages first he said then compare and
reconstruct classify first
yes it's called mass comparison take a
huge number of languages and look for
patterns in them patterns in vocabulary
but also in their typology the
comparative structure of the world's
languages you know stuff like how many
vowels does it have
what's its basic word order he cast his
net wide and caught some huge and
controversial super families
indo-european Turkic Mongolian Japanese
and more belong to Eurasia attic and
this one drew tons of flak but the
complicated languages of the Americas
are one happy aberrant family then in
the 90s merritt Roulin ran all the way
he compared vocabulary from across the
globe and reconstructed 27 proto words
here it was our first look at the parent
of all living tongues proto world or
proto-human and proto sapiens if that's
your style proto world had words like
theke coo ma aqua Kuna a decade later he
went after the typology of proto world
apparently our ancestors spoke their
sentences with a subject than an object
than a verb
they put adjectives before nouns and
instead of prepositions they used
postpositions
were we finally staring into the face or
the tongue of that long-lost original
language historical linguists said nah
and they tore into these results these
short words could easily be chance
look-alikes you can't account for
borrowings the meanings of your cognates
are all over the place your flimsy
method lets you base reconstructions on
irrelevant evidence
thus they confidently toss masse
comparison into the bins of fringe
linguistics pseudoscience and yet
babbles first and biggest claim lingers
the Maverick still swear we're onto
something are we or are they telling yet
another tall tale stick around and
subscribe for language
[Music]
you